hey
bet they thought they're gonna get away
with this huh
excuse me brittany and kayla didn't make
it to the dance camp
didn't the school call you no kayla's
sick
i kept her home this weekend i was sure
they were doing this together you know
they're with their secret plans
no way what dad pull over it's brit
what are you doing here i'm going to
that stupid ballet thing
duh do you think i could talk to kayla
her dad took her to the doctor did she
call me when she's back of course
you need to tell her dad that you don't
know where she is
no
hey what happened to your face looks
like you got hit is there a bathroom
nearby
can we pull over now
i'm scared she can't be trusted to talk
to brittany's dead
[Music]
get down where's your friend okay
whatever this game is that you're
playing it's over where's brittany get
off me dad get out of here i'm going to
the police
how do you want to do something really
bad
i pushed her
that's second-degree murder
there's something wrong with her she was
such a happy
little girl okay this friend her father
came by the house acting strange
did bernie ever talk about her father
she told me that he
hits her you release your temper with
your kid
who told you this does he really hit her
no oh yes i learned from the best
whatever you want to believe should
[Music]
what don't look at me like that
you